now to ukraine where the country's
foreign minister is pleading with the
u.s and its allies to send more heavy
weapons to push back a powerful russian
offensive new video shows russia
bombarding ukrainian positions with next
generation warheads also known as vacuum
bombs the overwhelming russian artillery
has allowed them to capture more
ukrainian territory in recent days mts
taeyab has the latest from the front
lines
this is what a russian victory looks
like
the town of papasna recently taken by
pro-russian troops is now in ruins with
the remains of the dead still lying in
the streets
moscow is throwing nearly all its
firepower at trying to consolidate
control of the eastern donbass region
where thousands of russian troops are
attacking from three sides
and are advancing much faster than
expected ukraine says it's now
outnumbered 7-1
but ukrainian forces say they won't go
down without a fight and it's these
howitzers they plan to win with
these american-made howitzers shoot
further move faster and can be hidden
far easier than other weapons and these
ukrainian forces hope it'll turn the
tide against russia
ukraine currently has around 85 of the
108 promised by the u.s lieutenant
colonel sergey zieka is the lead trainer
here
if you get more howitzers do you think
that it could tip the balance of this
war in favor of ukraine
yes the more howitzers we have the
easier it will be to fight russians he
says
it was the howitzer that was able to
push back russian forces shelling our
team
when we were with the ukrainian military
near the curson front lines earlier this
week
a nimble but mighty weapon against
russia's advancing army for cbs mornings
i'm impeached near the kursan front line